[Music]  it's time for et's kardashian Pecha i  just go with how I feel on Sundays  Keeping Up with the Kardashians  Khloe confronts Caitlyn about why  they've lost touch for me you're all I  remember Bruce was so not having you in  my life it's a huge blow cuz I'm like  okay my second dad this guy that I've  grown up with that raised me was taken  away from me but no one really let me  have that also on Sunday's episode Scott  Disick gets honest about portney I'm  still like turned on by her if that's  what you're asking do you see other  people at the moment no you're not  getting over her right no I mean I said  I would never be over her okay she's a  love my wife but check out this new pic  of Kourtney stepping up for dinner with  Diddy's 25 year old son Quincy Brown on  Wednesday night the pair dine to  Hollywood hotspot Craig's and court kept  it casual and ripped jeans and a rocker  tee really cute